New this morning,
the Wagner
military group
is threatening to leave
the Ukrainian city of Bakhmut
This is in the eastern
part of the country
where we've seen
some of the fiercest fighting.
Wagner's leader
Yevgeny Prigozhin
says his troops
are running out of ammunition.
So this private military group
has played a key role
in Russia's war in Ukraine,
but they've also been engaged
in this backroom
bickering with the Russian Defense
Ministry. With me now is retired U.S.
Army Brigadier General Steve Anderson.
General,
thanks so much for being with us.
Two questions about this claim
from the volunteer group here.
Number one,
and I'm not sure we believe them,
first of all,
but if you did pull out of Bakhmut,
what would that mean
for the military situation there?
But two, and perhaps more importantly,
what does this bickering
tell us about discipline
and coordination inside
the Russian military?
Well, thank you, John.
What it tells us
is that it's a really bad army
and they've got a lot of issues.
I mean, mercenaries
make great security guards.
They don't make good soldiers.
And we're seeing that play out
right here.
I mean, obviously,
this is
be a terrible blow
to the Russian military.
They're trying to fight
for the city of buck moot.
I can imagine
if General Patton
in the middle of his assault
on Germany in 1944 and said, you know,
I'm not getting all the ammo I need,
I'm pulling a third army
out of this fight here.
I mean, it's ridiculous.
It just shows
how poorly led, how poorly equipped,
how poorly trained and what a bad army
the Russian army is.
They're ten years away
from being a competent fighting force.
General, a key
piece of reporting from our Alex Moore.
Mark Warner, senior Pentagon
reporter, and his team
saying that the Ukrainians on the ground
and U.S.
officials are concerned
that the Russians have been able to jam
electronically jammed
the guidance system of the high Mars.
This is the artillery rocket system
that the U.S.
has been providing
to the Ukrainians
that that has shown some success
on the ground.
How significant would that be?
Well, it is significant.
I mean, you need the high marks
to conduct the deep strikes
that they're going to need.
I mean,
if they're going to conduct
a counteroffensive,
they're going to have to achieve
a breakthrough somewhere
and they're going to have to use their
superior maneuver and their ability
to integrate indirect fire,
direct fire and aviation.
And of course, the high Mars
is a very key component
of this indirect fire capability.
My big concern about the high margin
is the maintenance requirements.
I mean, my understanding
is that many of them,
perhaps
as much as 50%, are not operational.
We don't have the
maintenance capability
and the repair parts
to keep those things operational.
The jamming, though,
of course, is an issue.
We just need more high margin systems
and we need to
use those time,
our systems effectively,
and that means maintaining them
appropriately.
You talked about this
potential Ukrainian counteroffensive
here. I have a map of Ukraine.
I just want to show people that, yep,
a river here, which is this key,
one of the world's key waterways,
but a strategically important waterway
in Ukraine right now,
you can see it divides
the Ukrainian forces
and the Russian forces
toward the south of the country.
Where do you think it would be important
for Ukraine to strike if it can?
Well,
they're got about a 400 mile front there.
The good news is that
the Russians are spread thin.
And what they've got to do,
they've got to find one place,
a weakness in that front.
And they need to penetrate And in order
and then they be it,
they've got to be conducting it
in an envelopment
that gets around them
because they're not going to be able
to go toe to toe with the Russians.
I mean, the Russians are too strong.
They're probably got a couple hundred
thousand troops in there now.
And they're dug in.
They've been there for a year.
They're preparing
great defensive operations
and defensive mechanisms in each area.
So they've got to be able
to find a weakness in the wall.
They've got to penetrate it.
And then you've got to use their superior
maneuver, their ability to integrate
aviation
ground, direct fire and an indirect fire.
All of that
and a synergistic effect to defeat
and envelop the Russian army
General Steve Anderson,
always great to talk to you.
Thanks so much for being with us today.
The fog.
The mercenary
chief is slamming
Russian defense officials
in a scathing expletive laden tirade
And he's warning Moscow
that he will pull his troops
out of the embattled city of back
in a matter of days
due to lack of ammunition.
And new video
posted to social media Yevgeny
Prigozhin points to what he says
are the dead bodies of Falcons
fighters and shouts obscenities
at Russia's military leaders.
We do major
items to
where
you think you are
the masters of this life.
You think you can dispose of their lives
if you think because you have warehouses
full of ammunition
that you have that right.
At San Diego,
the Kremlin is declining to comment.
But Kiev is calling the new decision
to withdraw from a possible
turning point.
CNN's Nic Robertson
joins me now live in eastern Ukraine.
Nic, given
how many months
we've been speaking about back foot for,
this seems like
a very significant announcement.
What's your assessment?
It seems to point at a significant rift
within the military hierarchy,
albeit to that.
Yevgeny Prigozhin Wagner
boss is not in the military structure
at all.
He has actually just in the past
a day also recruited the deputy
defense minister who was
who was let go from his position
only last week.
So it does seem to indicate
that he has some favor
within the military hierarchy,
but specifically in that video
calling out the defense
minister, Sergei Shoigu,
the Army defense chief of chief of staff,
Vasily Garrus himself, calling him out,
laying at their feet specifically
that they're allowing his fighters
to die.
Now, Ukrainian officials,
as you say, is saying perhaps
if the Russians don't
turn around their ammunition
supply and back
would which they assess
that Wagner has been
in the vanguard of that fight
for a good part of the last nine months,
a significant reason,
they say,
why the Russians have been able
to take so much ground, in fact.
But they say if they
if the Russians don't turn around
that that ammunition supply,
then indeed
this could be a turning point
for Ukrainian forces.
The assessment is that potentially Wagner
here is
Yevgeny Prigozhin,
and the company itself is recognizing
that they are being so badly
decimated, losing so many people.
One Ukrainian official said
if he is losing 100 a day men.
That's the level they see it.
If he is losing that many a day,
he cannot sustain it.
And this will break the Wagner
organization.
So he has no option to leave.
But I think there's a telling line
in what is going to be,
Prigozhin said later today
following that threat to pull out,
he said We will go away
to lick our wounds and we'll rise again
when the Russian nation needs us,
when the Russian nation.
So he is appealing to others
outside of the Kremlin.
So this ends
strongly of a significant rift
that is really thrusting itself into
and into public.
Just when it appeared
that Russia was getting closer
to actually
being able to take the whole look back,
that's now in question.
And that's
very significant for the
for the Ukrainian counteroffensive
if it's coming as well.
Yeah, fascinating,
Nick, seeing the domestic
political turmoil
playing out on the battlefield as well.
CNN's Nic Robertson for us
in Eastern Ukraine. Thank you.
On the heels of the alleged drone strike
in the Kremlin, a warning
today from the Russian deputy
foreign minister
about worsening relations
between Moscow and Washington.
Sergei
Ryabkov says that the two countries
are on the verge of open armed conflict.
He tells state run media
that Washington has long
been a direct party
to the Ukrainian conflict,
and he says that it seeks to destroy
a sovereign Russia.
Alex Marquardt joins me now
from Washington with more on this.
Alex, obviously
this is a deeply terrifying statement
to hear.
We know that Russia's
rhetoric can often be bellicose.
But help us understand
why it would even be in
Russia's interest
to make these unsubstantiated claims
and essentially suggest
they're on the warpath with the world's
most powerful military.
Well, the simple answer is to justify
some kind of escalate escalation
and increased attacks on on Ukraine
and Kiev itself.
This really is escalatory language.
Bianca
it is extraordinary to hear Russia
not just accuse the U.S.
of really
being the power behind Ukraine,
but accuse the U.S.
of having direct involvement
for having a hand in
what the Kremlin has called
an act of terrorism,
an attempted assassination
of the Russian president.
At the same time,
It is very much in line with what
we have heard
for the past 15 months of this war,
that it is really the US and Naito
that are telling Ukraine what to do.
And Russia
is in fact
fighting against all of naito
in there in their war in Ukraine.
Now, of course,
this has been forcefully
rejected by the United States.
The U.S.
says they are still very much
looking into
what happened at the Kremlin
two nights ago.
They are poring over intelligence,
but the White House has said
quite forcefully
that the US, of course,
had no hand in this
and have said what
Russia is accusing them of
are ludicrous lies.
Take a listen to a bit more of
the White House's John Kirby
Look, I know
there's been
a lot of questions
over the last 24 hours or so
about this alleged
drone attack at the Kremlin.
We're still
trying to gather information
about what happened,
and we just don't have
conclusive evidence one way or the other.
I know there's lots of questions,
but we just don't have
conclusive evidence.
One thing I can tell you for certain
is that the United States
was not involved in this incident
in any way, contrary to Mr. Peskov lies.
And that's what they are, just lies.
So Peskov,
the Kremlin spokesman,
was the first person
to make these accusations.
He did not present any evidence
of any U.S.
involvement.
And, of course, Bianca, we've heard
Ukraine deny any involvement,
not just publicly
President Zelensky himself
denying it publicly, but privately.
We are told
that the
that in conversations
between Washington
and Kiev, that Ukrainian officials
have told the White House
that they had no role in this either.
I was also told by a U.S.
official
that in those conversations
with Ukrainian officials
that those Ukrainian officials appeared
rather surprised
and caught off guard by this. Bianca,
Alex Marquardt for us
in Washington, thank you so much.